this year U.S companies are on Pace to
bring 350 000 jobs back home from
overseas the highest number on record
for decades American companies boosted
their profit margins by offshoring
sending jobs to foreign countries to be
done by workers there for lower pay
typically the jobs have gone to China or
other countries in Southeast Asia but
that trend has been reversing and
American companies are now reshoring I'm
going to tell you why this is happening
what it could mean for the U.S economy
and why it may not be an outright win
for blue-collar American workers let's
get into it GE Appliances Stanley Black
and Decker and caterpillar each restored
about 2 000 jobs over the last decade in
2022 U.S companies like Intel and Micron
and even foreign companies like Honda
and LG energy have announced plans for
new us-based factories and new jobs that
had been largely or entirely done
overseas what happened covid-19 showed
many companies that they're just in time
Supply chains weren't strong enough to
handle a major shock and the war in
Ukraine tensions between China and
Taiwan and increasing droughts in
extreme weather events Illustrated that
Global uncertainties could stop
businesses cold the U.S China trade war
and tariffs introduced in recent years
have also made it more expensive for
companies to ship goods around the globe
on the other side the chips and science
Act and the inflation reduction act
which were passed this year offered tax
breaks and other incentives to companies
for building and investing in the U.S
this can be a major Boon for the economy
as American companies look to build and
expand and foreign companies look to
move on to U.S soil billions of dollars
have already been pledged for new
facilities making electric vehicles
batteries semiconductors and
Manufacturing equipment this year and
the U.S is on Pace to add more than 50
times the number of jobs that were
reshored in 2010 this year companies are
spending big while this would be good
news for the economy and large firms the
blue-collar workers whose jobs were
outsourced and offshored may not have as
much reason to celebrate that's because
a lot of what's motivating the restoring
trend is automation companies these are
investing in workers but they're also
buying robots that replace them this is
happening in manufacturing but also in
Industries like Trucking Agriculture and
Retail the association for advancing
automation reported that 12 305 robots
were sold in the second quarter a record
high for the third quarter in a row
research from MIT published earlier this
year found that automation was the main
factor Behind Rising wage inequality in
the U.S Durana semiglue who co-authored
the report tells me he expects the trend
of automation increasing inequality to
continue but he says robots can also
create more jobs and overall the trend
of companies opening up new factories
and expanding their U.S operations is
something the whole U.S economy should
be excited about Atlanta rapper j.i.d
reminds us to keep our priorities
straight he says forget a net worth I
made a million off of merch pay the
bills first and then invest in guest
verses
that's all for now see you next time